the Joe Rogan experience that looks
pretty badass oboe and pop that's in
Waterworld not the movie right that's
not water world's a terrible moving
water world's a terrible movie but they
have a damn good themed show it's very
good it's really good but it's amazing
it's like nobody watch that [ __ ]
movie it was a gigantic flop yeah but
still in 2018
they put on a jamming live show kicks
ass
Waterworld so everybody's like what the
[ __ ] is this based on this is some sort
of dystopian world where like everybody
is drowning right yeah the waters risen
to the top of everything and these
baddies and good people and and then the
stunt people that are risking their
lives is explosions of fire oil flying
jet skis it's great we got [ __ ]
drenched by the way if you're gonna go
to see this good seats don't go during a
cold day it doesn't matter good or bad
seats man that [ __ ] goes up into the
15/16 throws look at that it's a good
production value it's great because it's
it's like a play but it's fun to watch
yes it's very enjoyable that's all Kevin
Costner had to do was just do this to
make a gigantic movie hopper that movie
was a I had some friends that worked on
it there were stunt people oh yeah and
they were just talking about the amount
of money that like whenever you filming
anything involving water like your
everything is insanely expensive right
cameras all the water brings water it's
wet everything's wet it's like it's the
whole that was crazy and it sucked oh it
did suck I tried to watch it actually
yeah [ __ ] terrible movie it's like
the Seas of risen and there I've got a
lint either if they live on this boat
yeah but like he's in like a fight for
his life and [ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ]
cigar in his mouth and they blows movies
yeah and they have weird like comedic
guys and then Dennis hoppers kind of
looks cool but it's kind of weird yeah I
see you like these guys are about to
shoot him he's got us
garnets mouth look everybody's dirty but
it's wet out it's like it's like the
water you [ __ ] dirty stinky [ __ ] just
there's water everywhere that's a great
point
Mad Max Max the dystopian Mad Max movie
was made at a reason to be dirty [ __ ]
plagiarists just jump in the water see
he's fighting for his life and he's got
a cigar his mouth spit the cigar out you
[ __ ] you're gonna get shot Jesus Christ
I did like that boat though that was a
pretty cool boat they didn't control the
whole thing yeah it's kind of it's bad
but it's not nearly as bad as the
postman the post Mosman was another
dystopian movie that was a colossal
failure starring Kevin Costner but Kevin
Costner who I'm not I'm not [ __ ] on
Kevin Costner I'm a huge Kevin Costner
fan I love that guy but he was in a
couple of stinkers that kind of shirt
tanked him for a long time the postman
from 1997 is one of the worst so bad
that I will get high and watch it
occasionally just for the [ __ ] yuk
have you never has even seen this one oh
yeah in the phone's commuter Ribisi
whatever yeah whatever yeah you get
kicked in the head there and in this
movie like who is he Kevin Costner has
to deliver the letters it's like this
big thing in the future there's no post
office anymore so he's got to be like
the postman but they're trying to kill
him look they're gonna [ __ ] get him
he's got to run across the bridge he's
like I've gotta mail what are you doing
the [ __ ] you doing with these letters I
gotta bring them important we
communicate is this all because of
Dances with Wolves was so good they
tried to like redo it get them back in
the woods I think this is based on a
novel if I remember correctly
see if that movie the postman is based
on a novel I think it's based on a
science fiction future fiction novel if
I remember correctly
I never even heard of that movie oh it's
so bad it's great yeah it is man in a
book okay yeah so yeah it's it's about I
think it might be like post nuclear war
or something who's trying to stop him
people don't like mail let me guess
2014 the other day we were looking at
Blade Runner was 2019 yeah oh really
the original one was 2019 Wow next year
flying cars Robo so off yeah that's so
well we might make it
[Applause]